les chantiers routiers les cônes orangés
et détours empruntés sont partout sur
notre chemin à croire selon certains
qu'ils se multiplient
c'est l'enfer prouver j'avais tout ce
qui est à peu près
il faut aboutir jours et puis il ya le
panneau qui indique la fermeture d'une
voie de circulation et qui souvent
provoquent des bouchons montre alors
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire rester dans
la voix qui est ouverte coûte que coûte
ou bien s'y faufiler à la dernière
minute
la méthode est peul pourrait nous
épargner quelques maux de tête la
méthode du suppose est très simple un
véhicule dans la voie qu'ils ferment
indiqué dans la voiture que est tour à
tour comme les dents d'une fermeture
éclair on parle dans les études
américaines entre autres d'une réduction
de 40 à 50% des distances ou d'aider des
longueurs de files d'attentes au niveau
de la congestion aux redskins de
l'allemagne et la belgique ont déjà
intégré la pratique à leur code de la
route au pays la ville de saskatoon a
aussi réglementé la méthode est peu
c'est logique de la halle obligé au
niveau du code de la sécurité routière
c'est une autre paire de manches je
pense que de bien éduquer de bien
sensibiliser les gens à cette méthode là
à leur demande et de l'utiliser de la
meilleure façon possible lorsqu'ils
arrivent dans une congestion et ils vont
le faire puis il s'en gardent comment
sur la route matin et soir et des hôtels
est à même de le constater les chantiers
complet que la circulation et les
patience de certains automobilistes est
palpable parce que c'est dû à la
pandémie à ce que c'est dû à
l'anxiété la frustration il ya eu plus
d'accidents on dirait qu avant c'est
souvent la vitesse et les gens se
suivent de trop près avec la rentrée
scolaire le retour au bureau et la
saison des chantiers encore loin d'être
terminé patience et courtoisie sont de
mise pourquoi donc ne pas garder en tête
cette méthode est peu ici qui me
permettra au canada montréal